[Musique]
un contrat sur la piste le Red Bull
bicyone est l'un des plus grands
championnats du breaking du monde et il
faisait étape à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
une centaine de biboys et big girl se
sont affrontés en duel pour une place en
finale nationale le 9 juillet prochain
la révolution
pour la plupart des gens qui dansent
vrai du coup c'est bien important ça
fait 12 ans que je danse de break et ça
fait la troisième fois que je participe
à la compétition pour moi le niveau
français c'est vraiment très très fort
je considère entre pays plus fort du
monde les breakdance
il y a 13 ans cette danse et pourtant
originaire des États-Unis et elle
mélange ou est sportive et figure
artistiques il y a pas de figure
imposées c'est moi personnellement
juge sur beaucoup sur la musicalité et
l'originalité les mouvements signatures
la patte des danseurs danseuses c'est le
DJ qui qui choisit la musique et
personne ne sait ce qui va y jouer alors
forcément il y a des musiques que des
bboys et big girls connaissent sur
lesquels ils sont entraînés donc voilà
mais aucun danseur danseuse ne choisis
la musique parmi les qualifiés pour la
finale nationale le bboy PAC pack c'est
un habitué
[Musique]
j'ai gagné trois fois le championnat de
France du coup pour moi c'est la routine
c'est la routine je dis pas que c'est la
routine mais je veux dire c'est que ça
je l'ai gagné 3 fois d'accord et moi mon
but c'est de revenir au top de mon
niveau pour aller à l'international en
France je sais ce que je veux j'ai pas
besoin la finale internationale aura
lieu le 21 octobre à Roland-Garros un
bon entraînement avant les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 ou le
breakdance fera son entrée pour la
première fois